Pippilotta Viktualia Rollgardina
Pfefferminza Efraimstochter Langstrumpf.
Pippi lebt ohne Eltern,
aber mit Affe und Pferd in ihrer Villa
Kunterbunt und macht, was sie will,
hat nie schlechte Laune
und unglaubliche Kräfte.
Erfunden hat Pippi die schwedische
Schriftstellerin Astrid Lindgren.
Als Geburtsstunde gilt
der 10. Geburtstag ihrer Tochter,
denn für sie erschuf Lindgren das kleine,
freche Mädchen mit den roten Zöpfen.
Die Verlegerin Silke Weitendorf
war das erste Kind in Deutschland,
das die Geschichte lesen durfte.
Sie war so anders als das,
was ich bisher kannte.
Sie war ja wirklich diese besondere Person.
Stark, mutig
und dann noch ein Mädchen.
Also völlig ungewöhnlich,
so etwas – so ein Mädchen kennenzulernen
oder von ihr zu lesen.
Als Astrid Lindgren das Manuskript das
erste Mal einem Verlag anbot, schrieb sie:
„Bitte informieren Sie nicht das Jugendamt!“
Nicht nur in Schweden,
auch in Deutschland kannte
aber bald jedes Kind Pippi Langstrumpf.
Kaum eine andere Nation hat sich so
sehr in diese kleine Naturgewalt verliebt.
Pippi ist auf jeden Fall
das Mädchen der Kinderliteratur.
Eine Kindheit ohne Pippi, finde ich,
als Mädchen ist überhaupt nicht denkbar, weil
sie einem den Mut gibt, ganz stark zu sein
und jede Situation zu meistern und einem
ganz viel Mut macht für alles, was da kommt.
Und die Kinder? Die finden sie einfach toll.
Es ist völlig egal, wann sie ins Bett geht.
Und sie kann halt… Sie hat ein Pferd mitten
in der Stadt und sie kann es hochheben.
Die hat so zwei Zöpfe, und dann hat sie hier
so – das will ich mir auch machen.
Aber auch am besten wäre es, wenn es zwei
Pippis gäbe.
In Deutschland feiern viele Buchläden ihren
Geburtstag, so wie hier in Berlin-Kreuzberg.
Wir verkaufen Pippi Langstrumpf
sehr gut und gerne, aber ich denke,
es wird noch mehr gelesen als verkauft,
da viele ihre alten Pippi-Ausgaben aufheben
und ihren Kindern wieder vorlesen.
So haben‘s wir gemacht und
bestimmt ganz viele andere Familien auch.
Starke Mädchen – die sind heute
genauso wichtig wie vor 75 Jahren.
Und so wird uns Pippi Langstrumpf
wohl noch lange stark beeindrucken!